it's 2015 and the world's most powerful
drug trafficker El Chapo is about to
escape from prison
[Music]
did you see it right now
he's gone sabor la de las autoridades
mexicana zaleska parson nuevamente do
the world's richest most notorious drug
kingpins broke out of prison former
cartel leader is considered one of the
most dangerous drug traffickers in the
world joaquín guzmán Loera better known
as El Chapo broke out of his cell by
crawling through a hole in the shower
the escape of chapo guzman translates
into two things more violence for Mexico
and more drugs coming into the United
States a chapo was the leader of the
Sinaloa cartel a murderous criminal
organization that has killed thousands
during Mexico's violent drug wars their
methods are brutal but violence isn't
what makes of chapo different from other
traffickers instead his legacy has been
shaped by two abilities transporting
more drugs across the border than anyone
else and always finding a way to escape
authorities that was until now after
being captured again in Mexico of chapo
is standing trial in the United States
it's the latest chapter for the world's
most powerful drug trafficker and to
understand how El Chapo got here it
helps to look at a single innovation the
one tool that El Chapo used to transform
the drug trade is the same tool that may
be its most elusive target still a
tunnel used by his capital
telling the master of tunnels prints up
tunnels his magnificent feat of
architecture and engineering being used
to smuggle drugs and it's like looking
for a needle in a haystack
there's not really any form of
technology right now that can discover
these tunnels being built the tub
this in 1990 federal agents in Douglas
Arizona found something new a
sophisticated drug tunnel to the u.s.
from Mexico and when investigators got
inside they were amazed by what they saw
the tunnel was 300 feet long and led by
an electrical system running along the
wall at one end a lever raised a
hydraulic lift that opened an entrance
in the safe house floor one agent said
it was like something out of a James
Bond movie in fact it had been built by
an architect working for El Chapo and
agents didn't know it yet but this was
their first sign of a major shift in the
u.s. drug trade in the 1980s u.s. drug
traffic had been dominated by cocaine
coming through the Caribbean but during
the next two decades US forces led a
crackdown which changed the drug trade
in two ways that put el chapo in the
right place at the right time first drug
traffic shifted two routes through
Mexico second as national militaries
worked with the u.s. to destroy crops in
South America traffickers focused on
drugs they could grow elsewhere
the coca plant is only grown in the
Andes Mountains but marijuana can be
grown in Mexico especially in mountain
ranges along the western coast and the
same is true for the opium poppy the raw
ingredient process to make heroin for
both crops the densest region of
cultivation includes the state of
Sinaloa the home of El Chapo Oh
chapo also had the ideal way to move
those drugs
unlike cocaine which is odorless and
could be tightly packed into a vehicle
marijuana is bulky and has a strong
smell but by using his tongs el chapo
could give massive amounts across the
border quickly by 2010 el chapo had
become the most powerful trafficker in
the country and as the Sinaloa cartel
increased their power their territory
expanded to include the entire western
half of the US border as their control
spread west one particular area became
crucial to their operation a suburb of
San Diego called otai Mesa
there are three reasons why they chose
Otay Mesa and understanding them gives
you a sense of how sophisticated El
Chapo's operation really was first it is
near to major transportation hubs
Tijuana and San Diego so drugs can
quickly get to the border and out to
dealers on the other side second it's an
industrial area across the border from
Tijuana's Airport meaning there's a
steady stream of noise and traffic that
make it easy to go undetected the third
reason is the soil to the west is ocean
where the ground is too damp into the
east the earth rises to become hard
mountainous rock
Oh time Mesa is located in between and
soil maps show a geological sweet spot
where the soil is soft enough to dig by
hand but strong enough to support a
tunnel yeah this is a stair system it's
about a 70 foot drop in November 2010
agents found a tunnel and otai mesa
built by the Sinaloa cartel inside
electricity powered lighting and a
ventilation system along the floor a
rail system allowed workers to remove
rubble during construction and then
transport drugs once they started using
it over the next few years agents found
more massive tons
[Music]
tones like these can take several months
and millions of dollars to build but
they're worth it the tunnels are so big
that traffickers can move multiple tons
of drugs at once as the Sinaloa cartel
continued building in Otay Mesa their
tunnels got more impressive like
building the entrance for one beneath
the bathroom floor while Chapo's tunnels
are dug so deep that ground-penetrating
radar can't detect them and at ground
level the entrances are hidden in clever
ways but El Chapo wasn't only building
tunnels to smuggle drugs across the
border in 2014 authorities raided his
safe house in the Sinaloan capital of
Culiacan but al chapo escaped by fleeing
through a tunnel
he didn't beneath his bathtub a few days
later authorities tracked him down in
Missoula world chapel was captured and
sent to altiplano maximum security
prison a year later he was gone a
leaderless cartel is in a row
protagonist so una fuga de película de
cemento this was the largest tunnel ever
built by the Sinaloa cartel it stretched
nearly a mile to a farmhouse in the
nearby field
a year before that field had been empty
beneath a hole in the floor authorities
found a motorcycle that El Chapo had
used to cruise through the tunnel in
less than 10 minutes in Sinaloa of chapo
supporters celebrated the spectacular
escape but his freedom was short-lived a
few months later authorities broke into
his hideout in Los Mochis Sinaloa where
he was arrested after a bloody gun
battle he escaped through a tunnel
hidden behind his mirror that led to the
sewer but authorities caught him a few
hours later when he crawled out of a
manhole and tried to flee jenissi narco
Trafficante door mio otra vez en el
final de Maxima Segura de el altiplano
this time he was extradited to the US
where he is on trial in New York City
authorities are so serious about
security that they shut down the
Brooklyn Bridge when a chapo has moved
from his Manhattan jail cell to the
courthouse but even as he sits in jail
El Chapo's legacy lives on
[Music]
in 2018 two major tunnels were
discovered along the US border in
Arizona one stretched across from Mexico
to the back of an abandoned KFC and in
California authorities found an
unfinished tunnel that had been equipped
with electricity and ventilation systems
that run on solar power another piece of
his legacy also continues in 2018 drug
violence contributed to more people
being murdered in Mexico than ever
before but as aspiring kingpins add to
the violence in Mexico El Chapo is back
in his cell at least for now thanks for
watching if you haven't already heard
we've launched a paid membership program
called the video lab it's a great way to
support our journalism and if you want
to join you can head over to box.com
backslash drawing